eri ardisson publicitaires producteurs
de télévision de l'émission télévision
sur tf1 romancier etc
enfin vous êtes un des hommes les plus
branchés de la communication aujourd'hui
et pourtant vous nous faites nous
proposer un éloge de la monarchie sous
le titre louis 20 contre enquête sur la
monarchie aux éditions olivier orban
alors vive le roi je crois que on y
arrive au revoir c'est à dire qu'après
des des travaux comme ceux de monsieur
chenu de furète duby finalement bon ils
ont fait une partie du boulot ils ont
démontré que la de la révolution
finalement ce n'était pas le grand mythe
qu'on nous avait appris à l'école
et puis moi je vais un tout petit peu
plus loin que je dis bah si c'est à bas
la révolution pourquoi pas vive le roi
vous savez qu'en europe il ya plus de
monarchique de république et qu'en
espagne la monarchie a c'est le
renouveau de l'espagne c'est la
renaissance de l'espagne donc je crois
que ça vaut le coup de se poser la
question oui mais est-ce qu'il n'ya pas
une sorte de contradiction entre un
comme on dit aujourd'hui un
communicateur entre guillemets très très
moderne comme vous très à la mode
et puis une passion à ses vieillotte
pour la monarchie belge croit justement
si vous voulez je suis publicitaire
c'est une de mes activités et je connais
la force de la publicité et je me dis
que maintenant que les spots vont être
autorisés à la télévision pour les pour
les hommes politiques bien à celui qui
aura le plus d'argent celui qui aura la
meilleure agence va être élu et moi je
sais comment on fait lire regarder en 80
président mitterrand fait une affiche la
force tranquille
le petit clocher le ciel bleu blanc
rouge enfin tout ça c'était un peu
pétainiste in séguéla s'essayer laquelle
séguéla qui la fait pas bon il était
pétainiste dont la fiche est un peu
pessimiste plus fâcheux l'ofce le ciel
bleu blanc rouge la force tranquille bon
et qu'est ce qu'on voit arriver quatre
ministres communistes
alors moi je me dis que dans l'avenir si
on a de l'argent et une bonne agence
tout le monde peut se faire élire
président de la république surtout que
maintenant que c'est au suffrage
universel
alors j'entends parler de candidature
tapis de candidature montant on a parlé
de candidature coluche
alors moi qu'une corrida non pas du tout
mais moi fait choses avaient plutôt que
tapie parachever le jeune j'aimerais pas
bernard tapie mais plutôt que tapie
président la république je préfère le
roi parce que ça fait milan qui font le
boulot oui alors oui j'ai lu dans toutes
les notices biographiques ont fait
remarquer que vous êtes né le jour des
rois je me suis demandé si c'était vous
font votre sentiment monarchie d'un
ehpad l'a tout simplement tout mon
sentiment monarchique vient de ce que je
viens de vous dire c'est à dire je suis
inquiet pour la démocratie réellement
j'ai peur j'ai peur qu'on ait la
naissance d' espèce de petit l'ère
médiatique comme ça et je suis né le
jour des rois c'est sans doute la
providence divine
oui et le 14 juillet que faites vous le
14 juillet je trouve pas normal que le
président de la république ça soit
l'endroit exact où louis saez a été
guillotiné
je trouve que poser son cul là où louis
saez a eu le cou coupé
excusez moi je trouve ça un peu triviale
inconvenable pas convenable et le jour
de l'anniversaire de la mort 2016 que
faites vous alors l'anniversaire de la
mort de louis saez c'est le 21 janvier
il ya quelques années il ya dix ans les
v6 personnes à saint-augustin maintenant
la chapelle expiatoire et bourré à
craquer l'année prochaine on est obligé
d'aller à saint denis ça prouve quand
même que l'idée monarchique avance ça
fait quand même pas beaucoup de monde ça
fait vendre ou non mais vous savez sur
tf1 dans la folie pas du tout quand on a
demandé aux gens aux français qui
étaient là cet après-midi-là sur tf1
combien d'entre vous serez prêt à
approuver un retour à la monarchie comme
ça s'est passé en espagne avec juan
carlos moi je m'attendais à 5% à 10%
vous savez combien 58 % des gens ont dit
oui devant huissier svp
j'avais inventé vous pensez que dans
notre pays il ya un vieux sentiment
profond pour la monarchie non je pense
si vous voulez que dans ce pays il ya au
contraire un vrai problème de vie de la
monarchie siècle les français ont tué le
roi
ils ont tué le père et tant qu'ils
seront pas réconcilier avec eux-mêmes
il y aura un problème vous notez au
passage que il ya quand même une passion
pour les grimaldi c'est à dire ceux qui
règne à monaco bah oui c'est un ersatz
jeudi que les grimaldi sont la revanche
de louis saez c'est à dire les français
ayant tué le roi bas ils se réfugient
sur stéphanie franchement un bon je
préférais marie-antoinette vous préférez
vous jeune homme bien bâti séduisant
vous préférez marie antoinette
non ce que je veux dire c'est vrai c'est
qu'on stifani on sent un manque on sent
un manque chez les français alors bon
bah c'est lady di et le prince de galles
c'est stéphanie de monaco avant cette et
sa soeur enfin autant prendre les nôtres
on en a nous des rois une une page qui
est très intéressante je trouve
d'ailleurs vous auriez pu quand même
développer davantage et que vous montrez
c'est qu'il ya des monarchies les
monarchies ne sont pas tout à droite et
certaines république ne sont pas toutes
à gauche
vous savez le roi et au dessus des
partis c'est un arbitre comme c'est sans
doute remarqué j'ai pris l'exemple d'un
match de foot bon et deux équipes ça
existait tout temps il ya les
conservateurs d'un côté les
progressistes de l'ofc a toujours existé
bon et puis entre les deux il ya un
arbitre qui essaient de faire régner la
bonne entente sur le terrain bon un jour
la coupe et la tête du roi alors
maintenant chaque capitaine de chaque
équipe essaie de se faire élire comme
arbitre bon vous imaginez ce que ça
donnerait au parc des braves 20 ans mais
mon bon voulant se faire élire comme
arbitre il est obligé de raconter
n'importe quoi à tout le monde ce qui
fait que c'est la prime au plus menteur
si suite il raconte le plus moi j'ai vu
en 81 les socialistes nous dire que
on gagnerait plus en travaillant moins
par exemple bon transfert succès pas
vrai oui après on s'est aperçu que ce
n'était pas vrai enfin jeudi pareil pour
la droite sous les eaux nationales ils
ont des nationales ils ont
renationaliser ce que je trouve un peu
dommage c'est qu'il n'est pas quelqu'un
qui est le sens de la pérennité de la
continuité du pays
penser que les rois l'ont davantage pas
c'est normal puisque après lui à son
fils après son fils à son petit fils
oui et pour vous la grande date a fêté
ça sera non pas 80 9 mai 87 et l'année
prochaine
ben oui il se trouve que en 987 cap et a
été élu enfin c'était pas le suffrage
universel c'était par quelques barons
par ses pairs il a été élu roi de france
oui et alors qu est-ce qu allez vous
faire c'est cette année là ou non non
vous pensez même que ça va éclipser le
nom je pense que si vous voulez il faut
quand il faut qu'on arrête de 2,2
magnifier on en parlera tout à l'heure
avec max gallo il faut qu'on arrête de
magnifier cette révolution française qui
est quand même été la base de tout l'est
de toutes les révolutions et de tous les
totalitarismes qui existent aujourd'hui
enfin j'allais dire alors on va y venir
tout de suite mais là dedans mais
simplement c'est louis 20 parce que la
vie nous on pensait qu'ils avaient le
comment le comte de paris mais vous avez
choisi un autre prétendant basse et
louis vinci wi fi et louis 20 le
modifiant un reportage il ya un
reportage dans le j'ai vu ça dans les
algues n'y a rien aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait il est pas mal il
établit à 28 ans ce qui est parfait
voilà alors qui est ce lui vint tous les
avants les capétiens il y avait les
mérovingiens et les carolingiens bon il
avait un système quand le roi amoureux
ont partagé le royaume entre les quatre
fils du roi
bon c'est une forme de parthénogenèse ça
marchait pas bien entendu les capétiens
ont inventé parce que la monarchie c'est
pas un truc est inventé comme ça c'est
ça s'est fait au cours des ans et ils
ont inventé un système qui est de donner
le pays à l'aîné du roi quand le roi
valet lester l'aîné quand il avait pas
de fils était son frère etc
aujourd'hui l'aîné des bourbons fall
aîné des capétiens s'appelle alphonse et
c'est le duc d'anjou
voilà et son fils s'appelle louis 20
parce que comme vous ne le saviez pas et
moi non plus il ya trois ans il ya eu un
louis 19 mon livre parle de tous et
bourbon de tous et toutes des derniers
rois de france ce dont on n'a jamais
parlé parce que comme comme l'histoire
est écrite par les vainqueurs les
républicains jules-ferry qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils en ont pas parlé
c'est pas les rois maudits cela les
miens c'est les superbes audi
c'est à dire que louis saez louis 17 ou
18 chars le dise oui 19 henry cinq
personnes les connaît donc déjà
j'essaie d'expliquer en les montrant pas
toujours sous leur meilleur jour
d'ailleurs j'essaie d'expliquer qu'ils
sont oui mais vous donc le comte de
paris vous le récuser comptait pas je
récuse pas du tout je voulais le comte
de paris c'est très facile à comprendre
le comte de paris descend du frère de
louis xiv bon violence une terre non
c'est pas une tare mais le duc d'anjou
descend du petit fils de louis xiv geste
est bien fait il est plus est n'est que
le comte de paris
ah bon il ya cinquante personnes qui
viennent avant le comte de paris alors
si les 58
si les sacs dedans il ya tous les bourgs
banc par vient tous les bourbon siciles
en sicile et 50 meur je reconnaîtrais le
comte de paris comme roi mais il faut
car les 50 qui meurt donc encore un
autre génocide
oui encore un monsieur alan forest vous
qui êtes un sujet de sa gracieuse
majesté elizabeth 2 qu'est ce que votre
réaction quand vous entendez un homme
d'aujourd'hui un français d'aujourd'hui
faire l'éloge de la monarchie avec en
d'intérêt surtout parce que c'est un
français qui est lady qui le dit parce
que chez nous bien sûr que la reine n'a
pas de pouvoir c'est un arbitre comme
vous comme vous dites c'est un vrai
habiterez de temps en temps il y à un
arbitrage comme cet été par exemple
peut-être non c'est donc en somme par
les détails avec madame thatcher
mais quand je
regard de la monarchie française
l'arrière les serres qui aurait pu être
un j'ai l'impression que les rois les
reines les rois c'est au tour de la
france n'était pas du tout des arbitres
quand même mais des hommes avec des
pouvoirs réels et les hommes qui jouent
et qui étaient des joueurs dans ce match
de foot il ya pas au dessus de louis
xviii qui à mon avis est un bon exemple
u18 est un roi très décriée dans le mal
et isaac on vous expliquera qu'il était
gros qu'il était pas très malin gabon en
fait c'est pas vrai du tout louis xviii
est un excellent endroit qui pendant 25
ans d'abord à garder la flamme vivante
malgré napoléon et malgré tout ce qu'on
tout ce qu'on sait et quand il est
revenu il a accepté la monarchie
constitutionnelle bourbonnienne qui est
un modèle regardez l'espagne
juancarlos gouverne avec un premier
ministre socialiste felipe gonzalez tout
se passe très bien
la reine d'angleterre a gouverné
carolwood sommet à l'information nous
est royaliste royalistes qu'est ce que
c'est non mais j'ai pensé que c'est bien
j'accepte la constitution britannique
parce que j'y suis né ça a toujours été
comme ça mais accepter ça ça ne veut pas
dire obligatoirement quand ils pensent
beaucoup je suis royaliste dans le sens
que je suis comme vous l'avez exprimé
citoyen de sa gracieuse majesté
mais si j'étais français je serais
république pour les mêmes raisons
l'accord est et vous bien chaud du vous
êtes républicain ou plutôt mélange moi
je suis de tradition républicaine à 10
60 et 100 je suis protestant d'ailleurs
c'est une double raison mais de toute
façon j'aime beaucoup le l'exergue que
thierry ardisson a choisi parce que
justement c'est un grand monsieur qui
nous a quitté et je suis prêt à
souscrire à cette phrase de georges
dumézil
pour ma part je donne la préférence
comme montesquieu au principe dynastique
mais comme je ne crois pas à ça c'est
vrai et il est incontestable que les
pays
enfin vers lequel je regarde
spontanément c'est l'angleterre c'est
les pays du nord c'est la belgique et
quand ils savent que si la belgique
n'est pas l'institution monarchique elle
aurait volé en éclats je suis aussi
comme vous j'ai moins de carlos qui dans
le fond a sauvé la démocratie enfin je
crois 80 mais mais dans le fond comme je
suis français et que je suis
profondément conservateur libéral et
conservateur dans le fond d'eau même que
monsieur
forest et loyalistes chez lui comme je
suis en france et que d'autre part j'ai
été élevé dans la tradition des lumières
a été élevée dans la tradition
républicaine
donc je suis républicain et
naturellement je n'ai aucune répugnance
contre la monarchie
bien sûr contre la monarchie
constitutionnelle parlementaire
cela va se lave à sannois et la réaction
de max gallo devant le discours de
thierry ardisson
je ne sais pas s'il faut rire ou pleurer
je dirais je suis plutôt tentées de rire
parce que parfois il faut bien être
cantonné publicitaire il faut bien être
dans la mode et je dirais que puisque le
figaro magazine consacre le même jour
s'attira à un million d'exemplaires il
ya figaro madame qui parle de nuit 20 et
cela il ya le figaro magazine qui parle
qui nous montre monsieur thierry
ardisson entre deux magnifiques
incroyable très joli avec des fleurs de
lys alors ça après tout pourquoi ne pas
vendre ce produit là comme une autre
mais s'il s'agit d'être heureuse parce
qu'il n'est pas sincère ça c'est parce
que c'est pas mon problème je dirais moi
je reçois ce livre je ne connais pas
monsieur thierry ardisson qui est un
garçon bien de sa personne et fort
sympathique et très belle et très bien
qui écrit très bien très bien et non les
pages sur luigi qui crie très très bien
mais je ne sais pas si c'est la peine de
débattre de 27 ans pour les 6 à ce que
je peux dire à vous comment prendre au
sérieux
me dire un livre bourré de formules du
genre la monarchie lave plus blanc
pourquoi pas c'est le nouveau style
proche je veux bien aller fait j'ai
souri j'ai trouvé ça très très très très
intéressant je crois que monsieur forest
a dit l'essentiel sur la monarchie
française
je dirais que les français ont essuyé
ont essayé la monarchie de 987 à 1789
puis de 1814
on peut dire qu'ils ont essayé le
principe héréditaire de 1814 à 1877 ils
ont essayé tous les genres ils ont
essayé
les orléans ils ont essayé de bourbon
louis xviii et charles disent ils ont
essayé deux empereurs et ils se sont
convaincus expérimentalement pendant
quelques siècles qu'après tout la
république c'est à dire la confiance
dans
gensse du citoyen c'était quelque chose
de très important un dernier point tu
veux dire quand un livre est bourré
d'inepties street jeudi d' ineptie lui à
en prendre une
une seule page il ya une phrase qui dit
ceci la guerre commencer par la première
république
en 1792 chacun sait en faire tout au
moins quand on a un minimum quand on a
utilisé plusieurs documentaliste il
devrait le savoir soyez très sévère à
leur égard chacun sait que la guerre a
commencé en avril 1992
chacun sait que la cour n'y était pas
formellement hostiles et que la
république a suivi la bataille de valmy
alors ne dites pas écouter vous avez
l'essentiel qu'on enseigne d'ailleurs
aux offres alors que les uns dont vous
avez en version je dirais un dernier mot
si vous voulez parce que au fond ça peut
couvrir tout le débat je crois que
rooney dans une dans une sorte
d'entreprise de grand détournement de
l'histoire de grande manipulation de
l'histoire soit pour des raisons
marchande soit pour des raisons
politiques on y reviendra
moi je crois que les français sont
républicains ils savent ce que la france
doit à la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen le reste est
littérature et cela amusant et amusement
les droits de l'homme et du citoyen est
amusé à londres en 1787 à paris et à
musarder sens ne vaut-il pas mieux
un président est qui
qui devient est une sorte de grand roi
comme de gaulle pompidou giscard
mitterrand
plutôt qu'un roi qui est qui n'est qu'un
petit président da du tout parce que si
vous voulez le président pour être le
président pour être élu va être obligé
de raconter n'importe quoi à tout le
monde n'importe quoi faire mais promet
un demain on rase gratis probablement
une fois qu'il est président il
rembourse pas seulement l'argent ils
remboursent le mitterrand quand il est
arrivé il est urgent de prendre des
communistes parce qu'il avait été lui
été commises en iran beau et puis à
partir de la deuxième moitié du cepd et
là il se dit comment je vais rester là
et ils commencent à prendre des mesures
en ce disant il faut que j'y reste
et puis peut-être que j'y revienne et ça
c'est mauvais pour la france c'est bon
mais jean leray bande à monsieur gallo
je gagne très bien ma vie dans la
publicité donc c'est pas des raisons ma
chanson aucune si c'est pas pour être
célèbre non plus puisque je fais de la
télévision par ailleurs si j'ai écrit ce
livre c'est parce que je pense que c'est
dans l'intérêt de la france de dire aux
gens et aux parents d'élèves jeu de dire
parents d'élèves l'histoire de france
quand on qu'on enseigne à vos enfants
est fausse et je vous en veux pas parce
que j'imagine qu'aujourd'hui en urss un
petit un petit soviétique quand on lui
parle des z'arts il doit avoir peur sur
le d'illzach vient il va avoir peur la
seule chose qui vaut moins cher les arts
ea pourrait quitter le pays mettant le
feu aux poudres tout de suite dès la
première page vous écrivez ceci je vais
lire lentement parce que il est de plus
en plus difficile aux intellectuels vous
mettez entre guillemets oui de condamner
staline en honorant robespierre de se
lamenter sur l'holocauste cambodgien en
oubliant le génocide vendéen est bien de
déclarer le goulag intolérable en
excusant la guillotine feu ne vous
attaquez le terrorisme en pardonnant la
terreur 1789 1917 même combat oui fait
pas quand même un raccourci et bernard
thorette annexé en résumé c'est à dire
qu'il a été résumée par vers leur pivot
russell qu'on lui depuis là mais je veux
dire
donc ça il faut reconnaître à thierry
ardisson le sens de son métier de son
talent car je crois que ces quelques
lignes vous évite de lire tout ce qu'a
écrit monsieur chenu sur la révolution
tout ce qu'a écrit monsieur rénale et
les révolutions ctp s'est élevé à la
prononciation
mais en tout cas vraiment ça nous évite
de lire tout parce que là vous faudrait
leur lit et nous avons et à partir de là
je veux dire ça a commencé vers 1975
à partir de là nous avons la vulgate
alors oui c'est l'explication dire que
sa part que j'étais en italie
dernièrement dans un restaurant et je
vois sur la carte fils est tes filets à
la robespierre j'appelle le garçon je
lui dis expliquez moi qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
il me dit j'ai dit mais comment tu
il me dit c'est les filets qui sont
coupés en dés on appelle sa filiale à
robespierre julie mais est ce que c'est
parce que le patron du restaurant et
monarchistes n'est pas du tout dans
toute l'italie les filets en des
s'appelle fidèles à robespierre voyez
l'image qui là votre baisse perd fumée
ou ccc qui s'il bien entendu c'est jules
ferry a déclaré nous ferons de tous les
français de bon petit républicain eh
bien vous l'avez fait c'est à dire que
quand les petits enfants sont à l'école
on leur apprend que louis xviii et nuls
que louis saez est un gros serrurier
alors qu'il a vécu vous savez que louis
saez a gagné deux fois plus longtemps
que le général de gaulle que la france a
connu son apogée sous le règne de louis
saez que louis xviii à réconcilier la
france en 1814 alors que napoléon avait
laissé une caserne on ruine enfin mais
ça vous ne le dites pas dans vos livres
d'histoire et donc on déforme les
enfants alors d'autre part et puis pour
progresser mais vous l'aurez voulu nous
empêcher cela devrait vous raconter ce
que vous appelez le lavage de cerveau de
chou d'amour pari fou d'amour
enfin voilà un enfant qui ont des choses
est plutôt fin pierre-joseph voilà un
enfant qu'est le fils du fils du roi de
france et vous savez que le roi de
france avait une une dimension politique
mais aussi une mystique voix off
sacerdotale là le sacre de reims était
un peu comme une ordination
on prend cette enfant on l'isolent de
ses parents il a 7 8 ans oui enfin
monsieur gallo nous expliquera si
c'était 7,7 et demi puisque
apparemment ce come back à l'oreille et
donc si vous voulez cette enfant on lui
fait boire de l'alcool ont le souffle
dont on le donne un cordonnier ont le
souffle
on lui fait prendre des pilules d'opium
jusqu'au jour on lui fait signer un
papier comme quoi sa mère l'a obligé à
coucher avec elle
enfin si vous trouvez ça bien vous moi
je sais pas moi je trouve ça
épouvantable alors vous dire si c'est
signé là vous faites un amalgame dit le
premier procès de moscou va avoir lieu à
paris mais c'est vrai les premiers
procès de moscou ont eu lieu à paris
c'est pas le pote a fait ses études à la
sorbonne
vous savez tout est parti d'ici et donc
on l'accusé c'est louis 17
c'est louis 10 et 12h on l'accusé
d'inceste voilà mais on l'a fait signer
un papier comme que les couches etc sa
mère avec sa tante que ça se passait
plusieurs fois il s'était fait mal avec
un bâton le prouve en jouant on a dit
que c'était sa mère qui lui avait fait
des sévices sexuels en famille et des
choses qui sont épouvantables enfin et
vous terminez chapitre ainsi après avoir
tué le père et la mère celle de louis 16
mars à l'être les terroristes ont
escamoté le fils essayant de jeter le
doute et le discrédit sur tous ses
successeurs
forézien temps d'inventer mais bien
entendu faurisson n'a rien inventé
vous avez une phrase dans mon livre
c'est hébert après louis saez est mort
d'une façon magnifique magnifique saut
n'a pas empêché qu'on l'enterrait dans
de la chaux vive avec la tête entre les
jambes
il est mort d'une façon magnifique
hébert a dit il ne faut pas c'est un
texte dé beir il ne faut pas que le
peuple sache comment est mort louis saez
il faut que le peuple garde enracinée au
fond de lui la haine des rois c'est de
la désinformation c'est celui ci à l'eau
mais c'est le bolchevisme parce que si
vous voulez c'est une bonne chose parce
que mes actes et je vous en laisse et je
voudrais parler parce que je veux dire
nous parlons quand même à des millions
de téléspectateurs en il faut leur dire
que je crois que de deux choses l'une
bungalows du courroux nous plaisantons
ondes ou plaisantons ce que fait
monsieur louis chevalier monsieur nuit
va monsieur thiriez
je n'ai aucune prétention nous essayons
de faire de l'histoire je crois que les
rois de france ont été condamnées pas
par moi pas par jules ferry et de même
nom paille ils ne peuvent pas être
défendue par vous pour une simple raison
c'est que les français ont choisi mais
pas moi je fais confiance à
l'intelligence des français les français
en 1789 ils ont pris la parole vous avez
lu les clés
et on vous devez y avait des chansons
vous laisser parler que le second fusée
- berne les français ont pris la parole
en 1789
ils ont pris la parole en 1814 en 1815
quand seulement après une année
napoléon 1er de l'île d'elbe est revenu
et il y a eu un vol de l'aigle je ne
suis ni robespierristes ni bonapartiste
contrairement à ce qu'on veut faire
j'ai écrit une biographie de robespierre
ou jeudi de robespierre ce que je pense
avec je crois assez de précision pour
qu'on ne m'accuse pas d'être
robespierristes ailleurs sa note
d'ailleurs strictement aucun sens
les français se sont débarrassés de
louis saez qu'au départ il était prêt à
prouver en 1789 se sont débarrassés de
de charles 10 par une autre révolution
qu'il faudra bien expliquer car dans ce
discours sensible qu'on nous tient
et en effet moi aussi je suis aussi ému
que vous à la fois par la fin de 2016
par la fin de marie-antoinette par ce
qui a été fait à son fils mais je pense
aussi que si des hommes personne jamais
envie de faire une révolution parce
qu'une révolution qu'est ce que c'est
c'est comme un vieux inverse un verre
qui tombe par terre et qui se brise et
tout le monde a des éclats de verre dans
les pieds et vous ne trouverez jamais à
part quelques fous des gens sensés qui
disent nous voulons la révolution si les
français apprennent 1987 à 1989 à 1789
ont fait la révolution c'est parce qu'il
n'y avait plus je prends un simple
exemple ne citons pas madame sévigny qui
voit les enfants mis à la broche jeudi
que entre 1703 et 10 788 il y a eu dans
le vivarais vous savez combien plus de
trente émotion populaire et plus de plus
de milliers de paysans qui ont été qui
ont été égorgés qui ont été passés à la
broche
les révoltes de va nu pieds est ce que
vous êtes au courant monsieur chaunu
vous devriez le savoir sur les vagues et
vous croyez qu'une révolution ferment
monsieur gallo bayiha par 500 brive ils
y allaient de profondes on à l'adf et il
ne galvauderont pas les chiens qu'ils ne
mélangent les brusques je dois encore
dire nous les lancerons pas les siècles
monsieur chenu bus alors qu'elle est ce
comics qui fait parler des khmers rouges
l'onu et arlon des sans culottes et non
mais c'est sur le site de contrôler leur
faisait de temps et vous êtes en train
de faire ce que vous reprochez à thierry
ardisson de faire c'est à dire en vérité
je dois dire que j'aime beaucoup le
livre de thierry rien de ça ne m'étonne
pas c'est un résumé non vraiment ce que
je pense et nous a coûté résumé ali
terre pas du tout c'est j'aime beaucoup
le lit de thierry ardisson parce que
c'est facile et très bien a rien qui a
écrit de belles pages et notamment les
pages sur louis 17 sont absolument
bouleversant elles sont malheureusement
tout à fait exact j'ai pas tout à fait
d'accord avec lui sur un certain nombre
de détails mais quand à la première
phrase évidemment il donne une manière
percutante mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
qui s'est passé sous la révolution
un certain nombre de choses atroces mais
enfin pourquoi il ya eu révolution
mais si leur évolution je vous dis
certains cas mais dans l'ue c'est très
simple ce sont les bonnes choses là
monsieur max gallo et s'écouter arabe
écoutez bien qu'avec la révolution quand
on ouvre un incontournable où ton dans
ce pays on entend votre dialogue avec
robespierre alors mais poser une
question précise
pourquoi yeux la révolution j'ai vu deux
structures de savoir rédiger vous le
dire si massivement accordé trois
minutes tout à fait la france est
incontestablement a souffert au xviiie
siècle d'une sortes d'excès d'état de
droit
la société française est une société qui
évolue qui est en train d'évoluer qui
passe d'une société d'or société
monsieur monsieur galons je vous ai
demandé trois minutes non je vous ai
demandé trois ris mais la primaire
ils se croient chez pas là que
j'aimerais qu'ils ne seront pas là nous
ne sommes pas invités
bon écoute et non non non mais si moi je
dis je décline bon écoute et non de
toute façon que les six mois par les
nous souffre d'un état de droit en 1770
vous savez bien qu'on ne peut plus
pratiquement le contrôle des parlements
sur le pouvoir est tel que pratiquement
on ne peut plus faire aucune réforme et
on loue 15 l'a parfaitement compris et à
la fin de sa vie s'est réveillé et en
1770 il a fait ce qu'on appelle le coup
d'état maupeou les français
naturellement les parisiens surtout on
était contre au début parce que les
parlementaires une autre attaque pas
systématiquement les parlementaires qui
n'ont rien à voir avec le parlement
britannique
ces parlementaires qui sont des juges et
qui sont de remarquables juristes et
auquel on doit par ailleurs la
l'extraordinaire qualité du corpus
législatif français
les ordonnances vous savez sont en
général mieux écrit qu'elle ne sont-ce
de la république et particulièrement
dans le gouvernement dans lequel vous
participiez parce que vraiment il n'ya
pas là uniquement que déchets de ne
confondez pas des sièges et le croissant
des palissades a confondu tout à l'heure
en partant de 989 à 10 789 à l'écouté
laissez-moi terminé jeudi que donc dans
une certaine mesure
vous avez un état puissant qui se
bloquent qui ne peut plus évoluer et une
société qui évolue et le roi ne le fait
pas évoluent mais le roi essayer de le
virer départ le est partout il a hissé
la cause est révolue est né en 1770
c'est ce qu'on appelle le coup d'état
maupeou en 1774
moi je ne défends pas quelqu'un de 16
comme mir l'homme du courageux mais au
point de vue politique c'est un désastre
en 1774 qui commencent ils à 20 ans il
va commencer par la plus grande sottise
ont finalement tout découle
il rappelle sur le conseil de maurepas
il rappelle ses parlement dont les
français précisément s'était rendu
compte depuis un an ou deux que qu'à la
limite les nouvelles institutions
étaient médicalement lundi les
parlements coûté vous semblez cahier
dolléans elle était close et de juger
été compensés de jean propriétaires de
leurs charges additionnelles si vous
n'avez même pas la majorité
pourquoi d'ailleurs non
comme je l'avais il ya quelques temps
déposé un recours contre une loi
électorale qui est approuvée par la
majorité des français ne savaient pas
concéder acheter sa charge au conseil
constitutionnel parfois je la prends mes
coups simplement merci une nouvelle gare
et simplement fall intéresse donc je
vous en prie max gallo ne suit vous
permettez puisque on s'appelle comme ça
encore d'habitude
écoutez je vous en prie ne nous ne
jouons pas au pub est en l'occurrence
alors maintenant je termine je vous
avais vous avez vous avez un excès vous
pouvais plus bouger et au bout d'un
certain évidemment vous pouvez pas fait
évoluer l'état par rapport à la société
vous vous avez recours aux états
généraux qui sont une très bonne
institution malheureusement que la
monarchie a laissé tomber entre
l'entente que nous et ils ont ils abouti
c'est finalement à ce processus qui est
excellent au départ mais qui devient
incertain avant tout à fait excessif
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
lean a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou